[Applause]
it all comes down to this whoever gets
this wrong will have to eat their worst
nightmare
that's good you're good it sounds bad
I'm sorry I'm really into this do it one
more time good
what is the rarest blood type
what is the rarest blood type let's
reveal our answers Mr Obama says a B
positive Drew says oh the answer is
a b negative
both of you
I'll step you're both gonna have to eat
your worst nightmare
I was so close if I had just put down a
b would I have I kind of would have
accepted that yeah
but since you're here all right you
first
[Applause]
are you okay are you okay
this is that nag reflex oh God okay what
we do for love what you do for love and
for the audience because even though
they both lost you all win
and why they chew I'll tell you what you
win it's big time you're all good she
says ooh you're all going home with a
two-night stay at getaway tiny cabins
located outside major cities across the
United States
[Applause]
yay
[Music]
oh my gosh you did well
thank you thank you for this time thank
you for the incredible book The Light we
carry
special with Oprah Winfrey premieres
April 25th we make this show for you
everybody so take it with you
[Music]
thank you